12 dankte helmut für einen artikel den
er mir geschickt hatte ein schlüsselsatz
in meinem brief lautete unsere lange
freundschaft ist ein pfeiler in meinem
leben
sechs jahrzehnte lang haben wir beide
über dieselben probleme nachgedacht
in unserer regierungszeit und in
späteren jahren als wir uns noch öfter
rund um die welt um unsere gedanken
auszutauschen
wir haben uns zu hause besucht
wir haben reden aufeinander gehalten
helmut war der laudator
als meine heimatstadt führt mich erde
bei seinem neunzigsten geburtstag
erwähnte ich dass ich als kleiner junge
nie zu erträumen gewagt hätte eines
tages mit einem deutschen kanzel
geburtstag zu feiern
im laufe der zeit
kamen andere freunde dazu der prämie von
singapur lee kuan you und der frühere
außenminister george viele wie schwer
ihnen heute hier im michel
das wesen wesen diese tiefen
freundschaft zu beschreiten
auch nach 60 jahren waren helmut und ich
nicht zum vertrauten du übergang helmut
ist die weide gegangen als in seiner
nüchternen art zu kunst studieren
wir können uns aufeinander verlassen
weil keiner von uns dem anderen etwas
sagen würde was nicht die absolute
wahrheit ist dass meine damen und herren
war insbesondere an helmut schmidt
er hat seinen beruf als sehen einen
praktizierenden politiker angegeben nur
sein verständnis von politik gegen weit
über das tägliche politische handwerk
hinaus er war pleite gebildet als die
meisten spitzenpolitiker der
nachkriegszeit am klavier war sowie
tools dass er mit dem london symphony
ein mutmacher konzept geben konnte sein
weg in die politik war fast dem zufall
geschuldet
seine erste liebe waren architektur und
stadtplanung hätte er am ende des
krieges die geldmittel für ein zu
aufwendige studium gehabt hätte er seine
außergewöhnlichen energien und der
länder dem wiederaufbau der deutschen
städte gewidmet helmut lebte in eine
übergangszeit wissen deutschlands
vergangenheit als besetzt und geteiltes
land und seine zukunft als die stärkste
wirtschaftlich europäische nation wissen
deutschland geradezu zwanghaft sorge um
seine sicherheit im kalten krieg und dem
willen
eine globale wirtschaftsordnung mit
aufzubauen müssen die späten hinwendung
von helmut sozialdemokratische partei
kümmert landeten bündnis und der suche
nach einer blog über wollenden
friedensordnung in europa und in der
welt
helmut schließlich in der pflicht sein
land aus den kästen in eine welt zu
fühlen
die deutschland nie gekannt hatte die
wichtigsten qualitäten eines verbs manns
sind vision und mut vision um der
stagnation entgegenzuwirken mut um das
staatsschiff durch unbekannte gewässer
zu steuern
helmut hatte diese beiden eigenschaften
nie für sich selbst reklamiert aber er
hat sie verkörpert in einer großen rede
vor der universität tübingen im jahre
2007 führte er die leitlinien auf
vernunft recht frieden glauben die sein
eigenes sein und tun bestimmt ich
zitiere
für mich bleibt das eigene gewissen die
oberste instanz über das gewissen gibt
es manche ley theologische und
philosophische meinungen kant hat das
gewissen als das bewusstsein eines innen
gerichtshofes im menschen bezeichnet es
war die verpflichtung gegenüber dem
eigenen gewissen die hermuth so nüchtern
und ernst im persönlichen umgang es
einen links motto würde ihn von diese
pflicht ablenken
machtvoll weil es ein drang das wissen
zu erwerben der sünde zu befähigen würde
die schicksalhaften herausforderungen
seine generation zu meistern
all dieses analytische wissen war
eingebunden in seine spirituellen
beziehungen zur musik in spitzen drehen
zu bach und mozart seine innere konzerte
konzentration wir mir ein stück erde war
so ausgeprägt
der sehr mit fortschreitender gehört
jährige kommt nur auf das notenblatt
strecken musste um die musik hören zu
können
diese eigenschaften verliehen helmut
freundschaften eine besondere kraft
freundschaft viel mut war ein partner im
streben nach wahrheit und weisheit mit
seinen freunden pflegte er eine
unaufhörliche konversation jede
zusammenkunft begann wo die vorherigen
geendet hatte so formal sie auch zu sein
schienen
wann seine freundschaften geprägt von
tiefer zuneigung
das gefühl war die andere seite des
understatement wer sich auf helmut ein
lehrer wurden sozusagen in einen orten
rekrutiert welche die suche nach dem
wesentlichen mit demut brade
ich zitiere wir haben alle mehr als
einmal gegen unter gewissen lernt und
müssen also alle mit einem schlechten
gewissen leben
diese allzu menschliche schwäche gilt
selbstverständlich auch für politiker
und dennoch geriet er wird nicht oft in
die klemme zwischen dem politischen
gebotenen und der friedlichen pflicht
denn helmut überzeugungen
bestimmten sein handeln immer politik
ohne gewissen
kennt ihr zum kämmen nennen hat sodann
ich seh politik als flug pragmatisches
handeln im dienste moralische ziele im
jahre 1977 in sande helmut deutsche
spitzner spezialkräfte nach mogadischu
sie sollten in einem hochriskanten
einsatz deutsche geiseln befreien
einige wochen später vertraute er die
qualen die er durchleiden musste bevor
der erfolg der mission fest
und er fügte hinzu wenn ihnen das leben
der 68 606 und der kommandos seine seele
so tief fühle wie können wir dann eine
nato-strategie implementieren die auf
der atomaren abschreckung und doch
als die zeit kam gehorchte helmut seine
pentile intellektuellen pflicht
wer sie mittels krieg raketen in
deutschland zu stationieren
und zwar gegen den wacker gegen den
wachsenden widerstand seiner partei an
diesen aussitzen pflichtgefühl wurde
helmut eine treibende kraft in der
europäischen sicherheits konferenz in
975 und in der förderung der eu zusammen
mit seinem freund sitzt es den 1
gott gebührt helms besonderen verhältnis
zu amerika helmut gehört jene
nachkriegsgeneration an die zu amerika
blicken weil sie entscheider besonnten
führungsqualitäten die beste und
anfänglich die einzige hoffnung für die
freien völker sei er legte der er an
amerika einen strengen maßstab und voran
der amerikanische mängel schwere zu
akzeptieren als die defizite von
gesellschaften an dir weniger hohe
bedingungen stellte nach seiner
regierungszeit schien der sieg
helmut nicht nötig zu sein
politische führer agieren im schatten
der vergänglichkeit sie alle
quält die zukunft er ist technisch stark
männer handeln als ob ihre
entscheidungen für immer gelten
doch ihre zeit im amt es gemeinhin
kürzer als der rhythmus der geschichte
doch im laufe der jahrzehnte führte
helmut die tiefere bedeutung von
verdächtig für ihn hin sein lebensweg
nicht verwandt sondern von seinem
gewissen ab er bereiste die welt und
schrieben projekt praktisch ein buch pro
jahr
er erklärte uns die welt läuft
er wendete und stehen an unsere pflicht
am ende seines lebens 14 glich er unsere
vornehmsten werde
er war eine art welt gewicht erlauben
sie mir
helmut noch einmal zu zitieren und zwar
zur moralischen verpflichtung der
deutschen legt eine doppelte einsicht
erstens es wäre ein gefährlicher irrtum
und real existierende demokratie zum
reinen ideal
das ist sie nicht aber trennt gleichwohl
haben wir deutschen unsere
katastrophalen geschichte wegen allen
grund mit sicherheit an der demokratie
sie immer wieder zu erneuern und immer
wieder ihren feinden tapfer
entgegenzusehen zu helmut neunzigsten
geburtstag sprache ich die hoffnung aus
der sie mich überleben möglich weil eine
welt
ohne ihn eine sehr faire werde ich habe
mich ehrt helmut wird bei uns bleiben
perfektion ist es stets auf der suche
fordern inspirierend immer zuverlässig
so würde uns für den letzten unseres
lebens begleiten
mit seiner hingabe und seinem stil
so hat er uns lehrt uns die wir die
zeitgenossen eines großen und guten
menschen seien durch